[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ولد القارئ احمد رفعت في قريه كوراجا في
محافظه كفر الشيخ المصريه والتحق بكتيب
القران في سن مبكره ليتم حفظ القران
الكريم كاملا في سن 12
ملتحقا بالازهر الشريف يتخرج من كليه
الشريعه والقانون قبل توليه الامامه
والخطابه والتدريس بالمعاهد الازهريه
ومبعوثا لاحياء سهرات رمضان في مساجد
متفرقه حول العالم
شيخ فاضل على يديه ختمت القران الكريم وهو
فضيله شيخي واستاذي ومعلمي الشيخ عبد الله
محمد السيد اسال الله عز وجل ان يبارك له
في اهله وماله وولده اللهم امين يا رب
العالمين ثم ختمت القران في سن الثانيه
عشره من عمري
وبعدها وصلت مع الشيخ حتى تدرجت مع عدد من
المشايخ
وجودت القران الكريم ثم بدات في ختمه
للحصول على اجازه متصله السند الى سيدنا
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم ثم الى الله
سبحانه وتعالى
وكانت هذه الختمه على يد استاذي وشيخي
ومعلمي فضيله الشيخ علي الزناتي اسال الله
ان يحفظه وان يبارك فيه وان يمده بمدد من
عنده وان يستره في الدنيا والاخره اللهم
امين يا رب العالمين ثم عندما كنت في
مرحله الجامعيه المرحله الجامعيه التحقت
بكليه الشريعه والقانون بطنطا
ومع اول عام لي في هذه الكليه حرست حرصا
شديدا كما علمني ابي وامي قراءه القران
واهتموا بذلك كان عندي شغف وحب كثير جدا
ان يكون لي سبق في تحفيظ وتعليم ابناء
قريتي القران الكريم ومن هذا التاريخ وانا
في السن اولى جامعه ولا كليه كليه الشريعه
والقانون كنا في عام 2009
بدات بدايه تحفيظ قران صغيره ثم مع الايام
ظل عدد الطلاب يتوافدوا علينا بكثره حتى
يومنا هذا انا هنا في البرازيل والدار ما
زالت بفضل الله وحوله ومدده وقوته الى
الان مستمره مع عدد من الاخوه الزملاء
الافاضل المشايخ الكرام لله الحمد الى
رمضان الماضي قبل ان اسافر الى البرازيل
كان قد ختم معي 30 طالبا وطالبا اولا
عندما انتهيت من الدراسه الجامعيه
فتحت مسابقه لتحفيظ تابعه للازهر الشريف
وتقدمت اليها ووفقني الله عز وجل واستمريت
في العمل بها ثلاث سنوات محفظ في المعاهد
الازهريه التابعه للازهر الشريف ثم في
ظلال ما انا اقوم بالتحفيظ في الازهر
الشريف ظهرت مسابقه للوعظ والارشاد فتقدمت
اليها واكرمني الله عز وجل بها والتحقت
بالوعظ في الازهر الشريف ومن دور الوعظ
اننا ننتقل في كل مكان يعني في المساجد
ليس الوعظ فقط في المس اجد كائمه الاوقاف
وهم على رؤوسنا اجمعين لكن الوعظ عمله
ميداني اكثر اجتماعي اكثر مجتمعي اكثر
فصرنا نتنقل في المساجد وفي المستشفيات
وفي اقسام الشرطه وفي السجون وفي دور
الرعايه ومراكز الشباب والمحتفل
الاحتفالات وما الى ذلك ونلقي كلمات
ومواعظ على الناس في كل البقاع وفي كل
الاماكن وفي كل الطبقات العمل
اديني في مصر يخضع الى طريقين لا ثالث لهم
وهو اما ان يكون منتسبا الى وزاره الاوقاف
او الى الازهر الشريف
الازهر الشريف الذي يقوم بدور الوعظ اسمه
واعظ اما في وزاره الاوقاف الذي يقوم بهذه
المهمه اسمه امام وخطيب الفرق بينهما كي
يتضح الامر جليا الامام والخطيب له مكان
مخصص لذلك وهو مسجده هو فقط يام الناس
وصلاه الجمعه والدروس المفروضه عليهم من
قبل وزارته اما الواعظ ليس مقتصرا على
مكان واحد فهو يتنقل يوم السبت في المكان
الفلاني يوم الاحد لا في المكان الاخر يوم
الاثنين كل يوم في مكان تاره يكون الدرس
ظهرا او عصرا او مغربا وتاره يطلب في
ندوات او حفلات او ما الى ذلك فشتان يعني
هما بينهما اتفاق واختلاف الاتفاق ان كل
منهما يدعو الى الله عز وجل ونسال الله ان
يوفق الجميع وان يعلن رايه الحق والدين
اللهم امين اما الاختلاف
امام الاوقاف له مسجده ومكانه المخصص لذلك
اما واعظ الازهر فعمله اكثر من اكثر
انتشارا حتى يعني ان الوعظ في الازهر عدد
اقل من ائمه الاوقاف لكن تاثيرهم ولله
الحمد والفضل والمنه اكثر بكثير ويشهد
لذلك المجتمع نفسه
الواعظ ايضا يقوم في حالات الصلح بين
الناس هناك لجنه في الازهر المصالحه بين
الناس كذلك له دور كبير في محاكم الاسره
للصلح بين الازواج عندما يعني يختضم
الخصام بينهما ويجلس بينهما واعظ من
الازهر ربما يكون على يديه هدايتهما ويرجع
كل منهما الى الاخر بفضل الله عز وجل
والنتائج في ذلك كثيره جدا لله الحمد
والفضل والمنه يعني لا شك ان القران ما
وجد في شيء الا زانه ومن تزع من شيء الا
شامه هكذا القران وهي بركه القران فعندما
تكون حافظا للقران ومع ذلك عندك بلاغه
وفصاحه وتاثير بالكلمه فان هذا له تاثير
كبير جدا جدا جدا فربما يستمع اليك بعض
الناس في صلاتهم وبعد الصلاه تجلس لخاطره
في المسجد يستمع اليك للخاطره فضلا ومن
شده حبه لقراءتك للقران فيعني القران ما
يوضع في شيء الا زانه دائما القران يعني
يعظم صاحبه القران دائما وابدا يجمع الناس
حوله القران دائما وابدا يرفع وينفع صاحبه
وخصوصا ان كان في مجال الداعيه الى في
مجال الدعوه الى الله سبحانه وتعالى
فالقران يكمل النقص الذي عندنا
وكلنا عندنا يعني من الذنوب والاثام
والخطايا والاثام الله به عليم ولولا دليل
ستر الله علينا لفتضحنا اعوذ بالله من
الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[موسيقى]
ان الذين سبقت لهم
منا الحسنى
[موسيقى]
اولئك
عنها مبعد
ون
[موسيقى]
لا يسمعون حسيسها وهم فيما اشتهت انفسهم
خالد
ون
لا يحزنهم الفزع الاكبر
وتتلقاهم الم
لائكه هذا يومكم الذي
كنتم توعدون
يوم نطوي الس
ماء طي السجل للكتب كما بدانا
اول خلق
نعيد
وعدا علينا
انا كنا فاعلين
ولقد كتبنا في الزبور من بعد الذكر ان
الارض يرثها عبادي الصالحون
ان فيها
لبلاغا لقوم عابدين
[موسيقى]
وما
ارسلناك الا رحمه للعالمين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حطت رحله القارئ احمد رفعت مبعوثا من
الازهر الشريف الى البرازيل في المره
الاولى لاحياء ليالي شهر رمضان وامامه
المصلين واثر عودته اصر القائمون على
المسجد دعوته من جديد ليتولى امامه المسجد
وتدريس ابناء الجاليه من اللبنانيين خاصه
ومن غيرهم وهي المهمه التي يقوم بها على
اكمل وجه ساعيا الى اتقان اللغه
البرتغاليه وهي لغه اهل البلد
صدر اعلان من مجمع البحوث الاسلاميه
للساده الوعاظ جميعا لمن اراد ان يتقدم
لمسابقه الابتعاز في شهر رمضان الماضي
وعلى اثرها تقدمت عدد كثير من الزملاء
ومررنا باختبارات اوليه ثم تصفيه ثم
اختبارات ثم مقابله شخصيه الى ان وصل
العدد مؤخرا الى سبعه عشر فائزا اكرمهم
الله عز وجل بالنجاح في هذه المسابقه
ولحسن حظي واليمن الطالع ان اكرمني الله
عز وجل بان قدر لي المجيء الى البرازيل
كانت هذه هي
الرحله يعني فاتيت الى مسجد البرازيل
واتممت هناك شهر رمضان المبارك والحمد لله
كانت يعني
رحله الحمد استفدت منها كثيرا وكان لها
اثر طيب ثم رجعت الى مصر
فما ان لبثت قرابه العشرون يوما الا واتصل
ببعض الاخوه هنا في المسجد مسجد دوبري
رايس وطلبوا مني ان اكون متواجدا معهم
بصفه شخصيه تعاقد شخصي وعلى اثرها اتمنا
الاجراءات وجئت الى البرازيل الحمد لله
الى الان وانا معهم هنا في المسجد مسجد
دوبري مسجد مخصص يعني له افضليه عن غيره
من المساجد لا نقلل من قيمه المساجد ايا
كانت لكن يعني بعض الاماكن في الاماكن لا
افضليه وهذا المسجد بحكم انه في السوق
يعني في مكان تجاري ما شاء الله العدد فيه
يعني تظن ان المسجد يوجد في دوله عربيه
وليست في دوله من دول امريكا اللاتينيه
المسجد في كل الصلوات ما شاء الله به اكثر
من صفين وثلاثه صفوف واربع صفوف من الامور
العجيبه يعني التي عندما جئت ورايتها هنا
ان صلاه الجمعه في المسجد دون المسجد
الوحيد في امريكا اللاتينيه التي تقام فيه
صلاه الجمعه مرتين ما شاء الله يعني يعني
من كثره الاعداد المصلين هنا تقام صلاه
الجمعه مرتين الخطبه الاولى باللغه
العربيه ثم الخطبه الثانيه باللغه
البرتغاليه
الجاليه هنا الموجوده يغلب عليها ايجابيه
اللبنانيه فلهم دور كبير لا ينكره احد
يعني في البرازيل عموما وفي اي مكان
يذهبون اليه ومن بعدهم السوريين الاخوه
السوريين والاخوه الاخوه المصريين ثم بعض
من الاخوه الافارقه وكذلك الاخوه
البرازيليين هنا المسجد هنا له دور وانشطه
كثيره جدا منها دروس للاخوه البرازيليين
للتعريف على الاسلام وايضا للتقرب منهم
والمحافظه عليهم والاستماع اليهم وتثبيت
الاسلام عندهم والاستماع الى شكاويهم
واسئلتهم والرد عليها وما الى وكذلك ايضا
حلقات لتحفيظ القران الكريم والحمد لله
ابلت بلاء حسنا
منذ قدومي هنا الى المسجد عملت على ان
يكون هناك وقت مخصص اسبوعي للجلوس مع
الاخوه البرازيليين وغيرهم من الاخوه
العربي الموجودين في حفظ القران الكريم
ولله الحمد يعني بدانا هذا الامر وكان له
ثمار طيبه جدا يعني نسال الله عز وجل ان
يتقبل منا ومنهم ان يثبتنا واياهم وان
يشفع فينا واليوم القران الكريم في الدنيا
والاخره كذلك المسجد هنا له ايضا مساهمات
عديده جدا فيقوم بتوزيع السلا الغذائيه
على الاخوه المحتدين شهريا وكذلك الوقوف
بجانب الاخرى المحتاجين وما الى ذلك فله
دور كبير نسال الله عز وجل ان يجعله في
ميزان الاخوه القائمين عليه وان يجزيهم عن
ذلك خير الجزاء انه ولي ذلك والقادر عليه
موضوع السنه الغذائيه يصرف شهريا للاخوه
المحتاجين في ذلك المقيدون هنا في الجمعيه
في سجلات الجمعيه تجرى لهم بعض البحوث
للتاكيد على صدق كلامهم ثم يصرف اليهم بعض
السلالات الغذائيه التي تساعدهم على يعني
متطلبات الحياه من ماكل ومشرب وما الى ذلك
وربما بعض الاموال التي يقتاتون بها على
قضاء حوائجهم كذلك الحال بالنسبه للوقوف
الى جانب الاخوه المغتربين عندما ياتي اخ
مغترب لا يعرف شيئا في المكان فياتي الى
المسجد فالمسجد بدوره يقوم بمساعدته قدر
المستطاع في ذلك اما في توفير سكن او في
توفير دواء او في قضاء ديون عليه او ما
الى ذلك او حجزي طيران او ما الى ذلك يعني
الاخوه هنا في المسجد يعني جزاهم الله
خيرا لا يقصرون في هذا الامر ابدا ما
استطاعوا الى ذلك سبيلا فجزاهم الله خيرا
انا اتكلم بصفه شخصيه عن المسجد يعني لحكم
ان انا اعمل فيه يعني
هنا درس ثابت
للاخوه البرازيلين عموما والبرازيليات ومن
اراد من الاخوه العرب يوم السبت من كل
اسبوع الساعه الرابعه درس لتعليم وتحفيظ
القران الكريم وان شاء الله عز وجل سيكون
في مقبل الايام درس للغه العربيه تعليم
اللغه العربيه اساسياتها وكيف كيفيه
قراءتها وكيفيه تعليمها حتى يتسنى لهم
اكثر القراءه في القران الكريم باريحيه
لانهم يعتمدون الان على السماع الشيخ يقرا
وهم يرددون مرارا وتكرارا ثم يقراون ويصوب
لهم الشيخ الاخطاء ثم يحفظونه في المره
القادمه يسمعون وهكذا والحمد لله رب
العالمين يعني هذا الامر يعني قبل بلاء
حسنا جيدا يعني له ثمار طيبه على ارض
الواقع يشهد لها الكثيرين به بفضل الله رب
العالمين
لا اله الا الله
رمضان له يعني طبيعه خاصه وميزه خاصه في
قلوب الجميع يعني فعندما جيت الى البرازيل
لقضاء شهر رمضان ما شاء الله كانت الادوات
طيبه جدا ما شاء الله يعني حب وتناسق
وتناغم بين الناس وتسابق وتسارع في قراءه
القران وفي صلاه القيام والتهجد والافطار
الجماعي الذي يعد في كل ليله وما اجمل
عندما يجتمع الجميع على طاوله واحده يعني
حاجه ما شاء الله سبحان الله ما كنت اتخيل
ولا اظن ابدا ان يكون هذا الجو هنا في
البرازيل يعني لكن كانت هنا كانت الاجواء
ما شاء الله طيبه جدا نسال الله عز وجل ان
يعني يديمها علينا دائما وابدا القران
طبعا له هو الحظ الاكبر في ايام رمضان هنا
في في البرازيل فهناك ختمه قرانيه يوميه
كل يوم يقرا جزء هذا بعد صلاه العصر ثم
الجلوس مع الاخوه جميعا في المسجد وقراءه
الاذكار ثم صلاه المغرب جماعه ثم الافطار
الجماعي مع الجميع ثم بعد ذلك كل يستعدوا
الى صلاه العشاء والتراويح وبعد ذلك في
ايام العشر الاواخر من رمضان ايضا تكون
الهمم عاليه جدا في صلاه القيام والتراويح
وتسبقوا فيها الجميع والجلوس في المسجد
الى صلاه الفجر ثم الجلوس بعد صلاه الفجر
لقراءه الاذكار وكذلك قراءه القران الكريم
في حلقات وتصحيح القراءه والتلاوه للجميع
ودائما وابدا هناك دروس في الفقه والسيره
وفي كيف كان صيام النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم وكيف كان رمضان في ايام السلف الصالح
رضوان الله عليهم اجمعين وهكذا تمر ايام
رمضان ما شاء الله لها يعني رونق خاص
وميزه خاصه لا تتواجد في غيرها اعوذ بالله
من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اذا الس
ماء
انفطرت واذا الكواكب
انتثرت واذا البحار فجرت واذا القبور
باسره
علمت نفس ما قدمت واخرت
يا ايها الانسان ما غرك بربك الكريم
الذي خلقك فسواك فعدلك
كثير اي صوره ما
[موسيقى]
شاء ركبك
كلا بل تكذبون بالدين وان عليكم لحافظين
[موسيقى]
كراما
كاتبينعلمون ما تفعلون
ان الابرار لفي نع
يم
وان الفجار لفي
جحيم
يصلونها يوم الدين وما هم عنها
بغائبين
وما ادراك ما يوم الدين ثم
[موسيقى]
ما ادراك ما يوم
الدين يوم لا تملك نفس لنفس شيئا
والامر يومئذ لله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]